in meinem vortrag geht es jetzt heute
ganz dezidiert nur um videos also nicht
um apps und sonstige digitale medien
videos gibt es ja schon seit längerer
zeit im einsatz dennoch stellt sich hier
ein wichtiges didaktisches problem
nämlich wie können studierende durch das
rezitieren von videos aktiviert werden
ist das nicht ein widerspruch
diese lose konsumieren die sich
zurücklehnen dieses anschauen betrachten
wie soll das bitte schön studieren
aktivieren ist das nicht ein widerspruch
und tatsächlich ist es ein problem ich
werde aber folgenden dafür argumentieren
dass das video als solches als medium
nicht problematisch sein muss nur eine
bestimmte form des video einsatz eine
falsche form also ist das nicht ein
widerspruch
nein nicht unbedingt sondern gut
gemachte videos können studierende sehr
wohl aktivieren als wir brauchen eben
videos die aktivieren sind aktivieren
die videos und keine videos wo sich die
studierenden wie im kino fühlen und sich
zurücklehnen ich will damit nicht sagen
dass nicht auch videos von kinofilm
format aktivierend sein können das will
ich damit nicht sagen aber ich glaube
muss hier wirklich ganz viel mühe
investieren um die potenziale des wie
die aktivierenden potenziale des videos
voll ausschöpfen zu können und in meinem
vortrag heute geht es gerade darum wie
können wir videos aktivierend einsetzen
kurz gesagt je mühlmann in die videos
investiert wirst du mir aktivieren sie
also die bloße aufzeichnung zum beispiel
wie es jetzt in diesem fall hier ist
deaktiviert noch nicht so viel da muss
noch ganz viel nachbereitung stattfinden
und darum soll es heute gehen was ich
jetzt heute berichtet ist das ergebnis
eines projekts was gefördert wurde in
diesem jahr mit dem titel blockseminar
wiki seminar die seminar und zum schluss
philo cast innovation integration
aktueller e medien im fach philosophie
ich habe in anderen vorträgen wo man
auch dann ein video findet das wird
jetzt gleich hier eingeblendet hier oben
habe ich schon mal was gesagt über das
blockseminar das wirklich semin
einem anderen vortrag in einem anderen
beitrag aber heute soll es dezidiert nur
um viel lowcost gehen wurde gefördert
durch lehre in diesem jahr sehr
großzügig bin ich sehr dankbar weil ich
ohne die mittel das gar nicht technisch
hätte bewältigen können und ich meine
sehr zuverlässigen mitarbeiter die sich
auch hier in diesem raum befinden hätte
bezahlen können dafür zunächst werde ich
jetzt überblick über die das programm
geben dieses vortrags ich will zunächst
was zu didaktisch philosophischen
bedeutung von videos sagen
dann will ich was sagen zur produktion
von videos das ist der technische aspekt
der ist nicht zu unterschätzen
dann besonders wichtig die anwendung der
einsatz von video video ist nicht gleich
video je nachdem wie ich das video
positioniere einbinde einbeziehen so
ändert sich auch die aktivierung und
ganz zum schluss möglichen
praxisbeispiel geben berichten statistik
analyse der bisherigen ergebnisse meines
youtube kanals philo fast philosophisch
youtube-kanal zunächst zur didaktischen
bedeutung von videos hier kann man
wieder fragen sind videos didaktisch
überhaupt sinnvoll
das ist das problem von anfangen können
sie aktivieren jetzt in weiteren sinne
sind sie generell didaktisch sinnvoll
und da möchte eben noch mal sagen video
ist nicht gleich video
es gibt eine ganz ganz große auswahl
eine große ein großes angebot an
möglichen videos wenn man nur mal das
medium video sich betrachtet da ist zum
ersten die bloße seminar aufzeigen
das ist denke ich so der standard da
stellen sich die meisten vorher ja ich
stelle ebenso ein camcorder rein so wie
jetzt bei uns und zeigen halt einfach
alles auf und wenn der vortrag zu ende
ist dann mache ich ihn aus und wenn ich
noch ein bisschen mehr mühe geben dann
nehme ich das noch auf mit dem la wally
mikrofon und blendet dann die tondateien
und habe ich eine bessere tonqualität
okay aber das ist so der standard ich
glaube wir dürfen hier nicht bleiben das
ist seminar auszeichnung ist auch nicht
seminar aufzeigen wir müssen uns hier
sehr viel mühe gegeben und wir haben uns
bisher zu wenig mühe gegeben die
dozierenden haben sie
regel zu wenig geben sich zu wenig mühe
dabei eine weile weitere videoform ist
die termine sind themen sendung
das ist eine ganz spezifische
entwickelte video didaktische
institution möchte schon fast sagen die
ganz auf das interesse einer
spezifischen studierendengruppe
zugeschnitten ist also hier ist von dem
engeren fokus der sendung schon viel
mehr aktivieren das potenzial enthalten
ich werde im folgenden noch genauer
sagen wie man seine themen sendung
gemacht dann gibt's zum podcast und das
ist bekannt ganz kurze regelmäßig
wiederkehrende folgen die so eine
gewisse gewohnheit struktur dann auch
entwickelt bei den studierenden da ist
die regelmäßigkeit ein wichtiger faktor
das darf nicht mal drei monate lang
nichts geben und dann gibt's wieder zehn
neue podcast sind jeden samstag um 14
uhr kommt dieser podcast und zwar immer
in diesem format immer fünf minuten oder
drei minuten oder wie auch immer
und die studierenden müssen sich freuen
wir müssen schon richtig aktiviert sein
durch die bloße antizipation das jetzt
wieder was kommen das ist das ist so
dieses diese aura die ein video um sich
herum haben muss also der kontext kurz
gesagt viel zu häufig konzentrieren sich
dozierenden nur auf das video als
solches man muss auch immer den kontext
mit berücksichtigen also die ankündigung
erwartungen jedes video muss im kontext
stehen das muss das nachfolgende schon
antizipieren und es muss bezogen auf das
vorhergehende es geht also um eine
gesamte gesamtheit struktur da gibt es
die möglichkeit dass man auf sein
interview macht das finde ich ganz ganz
sinnvoll also eine themen art themen
sendung aber mit einem experten an einer
expertin werde ich nachher video
einsenden wenn das technisch möglich ist
das ist eine möglichkeit und so weiter
und so fort hier gibt es noch viele
andere formate habe ich werde mich heute
auf diese drei also themen sendung
podcast interview
konzentrieren kurz gesagt aufzeichnungen
versus dramaturgen und wir müssen nicht
nur regisseure und dramaturgen sein
sondern wir müssen auch manager sein
managerin wir müssen auch ja medien wie
soll ich sagen medien medienmanager sein
kann man schon fast sagen wir müssen
schauen wie wir das video an den mann an
die frau bringen
das ist ganz wichtig und youtube ist die
ideale plattform um sowas zu tun werde
ich aber erst mal kurz was sagen
zur art der produktion von videos video
produziert man nicht nur so dass man
jetzt hier so ein camcorder einstellt
und dann auf den aufnahmeknopf drücken
und dann wenn das der vortrag oder was
auch immer zu ende ist nochmal auf den
aufnahmeknopf drücken damit es dann
aufgenommen ist sondern gehört ganz
schön viel know how und
hintergrundwissen und erfahrung auch
dazu kurz gesagt ist man mit 1000 euro
schon auf einem recht guten niveau mit
dabei also dieses setting hier in diesem
raum mit diesem camcorder und allem drum
und dran das kriegt man gut 4000 euro
ich lese jetzt mal kurz auf also
camcorder für videos über 20 minuten
muss ich dazu sagen also der camcorder
ist jetzt das ideale medien gerät für
diesen vortrag hier über 20 minuten ca
200 euro vielleicht auch 950 euro gegen
sie eine wirklich gute qualität ich kann
da auch eine empfehlung noch aussprechen
digitale spiegelreflexkameras sind
geeignete videos bis 20 minuten oder
idealerweise sogar nur bis 10 15 minuten
warum die werden häufig zu heiß einfach
die haben eine so hohe auflösung eine so
hohe qualität der aufnahmen dass die das
nicht schaffen eine stunde lang
aufzunehmen zumal auch die bild die
dateigröße diese videos dann ins
unermessliche gestalten also wenn ich
mit einer digitalen spiegelreflex mit
einer extrem guten qualität und
auflösung eine 90-minütige
seminarveranstaltung aufnehmen dann bin
ich vielleicht bei 200 gigabyte oder
vielleicht sogar bei 300
arbeiten und so ein speichermedium gibt
es zwar in diesem camcorder finden sich
200 gb es ist es ist die sd karte
aber das hat auch nicht jedem so teuer
also ich würde empfehlen für seminar
aufzeichnung von vorlesungen nehmen sie
ein camcorder und themen sendungen
podcast interview es bis 20 minuten
idealerweise bis 10 sogar nur nehmen sie
dann digitale spiegelreflexkamera die
kostet allerdings dann so um die 500
euro
stative sind ganz wichtig die der
camcorder muss gut fixiert sein er muss
auch geschützt werden gegenüber stößen
oder sonstigen einflüssen das wird sich
sehr negativ auf die bildqualität aus
auch gibt es die möglichkeit ein green
screen sich an zu schaffen wir haben das
jetzt gemacht also das ist eigentlich
nur so ein leintuch mit einer ganz
bestimmten farbe das ist eine farbe die
ist künstlich die kommt sogar nicht mehr
natürlich ein bild vor und deswegen
lässt sie sich sehr gut isolieren
ja das ist dann also sehr guter
hintergrund vor dem man bestimmte dinge
in abhebung bringen kann zum beispiel
eine person die eben etwas doziert vor
diesem hintergrund
wir haben uns das gekauft das kostet das
ist dieses line druckkosten 50 euro
idealerweise spannt man das noch an eine
ein ständer damit sich keine falten
ergeben die dann wiederum sich negativ
auswirken auf die bildqualität aber wenn
man das schon hin klebt an die wand geht
es auch in 50 euro belichtung ist ganz
wichtig um schattenwurf zu vermeiden
dieses green screens gibt es auch für
100 euro tonaufnahme gerät ganz wichtig
hätte man noch einen eigenen vortrag der
behalten können die tonqualität ist in
einem video fast wichtiger als die
videoqualität
es ist eben wieder so der lerntyp der
akustische lerntyp den darf man nicht
unterschätzen
diese lose bild bringt fast keine
informationen dass ich hier rumstehen
gestikulierend mal hin deutsche und so
selbst dass ich jetzt hier hindeutet
sagt gar nichts wenn ich nicht dabei
auch verbalisieren unterschätzen sie
also nicht die die bedeutung des tones
bzw des wortes und deswegen muss eine
sehr gute tonqualität vorhanden
ein videoschnittprogramm da gibt es ganz
verschiedene es gibt auch freeware
aber ich sag mal so um die 200 euro wenn
sie natürlich noch professioneller sein
wollen müssen sie sich dann von adobe
dieses premier kaufen
das kostet dann im monat vielleicht 50
euro das so ich persönlich bin großer
freund von programmen die man einmal
kauft und an die ganze zeit benutzen
kann und nicht die man von monat zu
monat eben mieten muss aber das muss
eben jeder wissen da muss jeder seine
erfahrung machen ich bin hat mir dieser
job programm jedenfalls auch sehr gute
erfahrung gemacht dann das würde jetzt
nicht als ausrüstung bezeichnen aber
jedenfalls als notwendiger kontext die
hilfskräfte von denen sich zwei hier im
raum befinden den ich sehr dankbar bin
die sollten eine gewisse technik
erfahrung mitbringen das heißt nicht
dass man sich das nicht aneignen kann
das geht alles ganz schnell ja wie sieht
jetzt seine ganze setting aus wenn man
alles parat hat das sieht dann so aus
dass unsere kleine studio sie sehen
nicht viel raum dass ein normales
sekretariat ist mein sekretariat
hier ist der kopierer und hier sehen sie
die stative mit den kameras wir haben
also drei kameras 123 wir haben eine
zentrale eine totale dann haben wir hier
auf die frau doktor sein dass eine
gerichtspsychiaterin ich kommen nachher
noch drauf mit der hatte ich ein
interview
die wurde von der kamera aufgenommen ich
würde von dieser hier aufgenommen
hier sind die hilfskräfte das ist der
tasche denn der auch hier heute im raum
ist das ist noch der uhren schalte
leider heute nicht da sein kann hermann
gute lichtquelle und hier haben ein
natürliches licht außenfenster muss eben
schauen dass das licht homogen ist und
deswegen brauchen wir hier eine
verstärkung
genau hier aber so als hintergrund so
eine bücherwand und so kann man
natürlich auch noch ein green screen hin
spannung hier überlegen haben auch schon
mal gemacht und kann man da noch effekte
dahinter legen
genauso sieht das dann am ende aus wenn
man diese ausstattung sich angeschafft
hat sie können die ganz flexibel
eigentlich nahezu überall installieren
wenn sie nur eine gute lichtsituation
haben jetzt zum einsatz von videos was
gibt es da für möglichkeiten zunächst
eben die reine dokumentation zum nach
das ist jetzt mehr oder weniger das was
wir auch heute machen
es wird aufgenommen es wird in irgendwo
in einem medium gestellt ins internet
oder auf den server und dann kann man
sich das nachsehen
das ist typischerweise eine seminar
aufnahme oder auch ein vortrag einfach
vortragen das problem ist zu lang zu
lang und nicht strukturiert
also wenn der dozierende der vortragende
selbst nicht struktur rein bringt schon
in den vortrag dann können sie nicht
mehr viel machen
sie können versuchen ihn zu schneiden
aber dann greifen sie auch in die
persönlichkeit oder autorenrechte dass
patienten müssen dass mit dem absprechen
der fühlt sich vielleicht gekränkt oder
so ich bin ich ein großer freunde rhein
dokumentations- nachsehen nicht lösung
besteht eben darin zusätzlich folien
einzufügen also zum beispiel bei diesen
vorträgen die jetzt während dieser tage
aufgezeichnet wurden da würden wir dann
noch im nachhinein ihrem einverständnis
die powerpoint präsentation noch mit
einbeziehen also immer zwischendrin noch
mal zur orientierung mit gliederung
einbeziehen und dann im jeweiligen
bildungs punkt auch noch einfügen
tagungs verträge sagte ich schon jetzt
ungefähr dasselbe diese dauert 30 bis 60
minuten auch häufig zu lange dafür aber
sind sie sehr häufig spezifisch also so
zu einem seminar aufzeichnung ist nicht
immer ganz spezifisch dann gibt es eine
diskussion dann findet man keinen roten
faden mehr so ein vortrag ist häufig
fokussierter aber auch häufig zu lang
für das youtube publikum ich komm
nachher noch auf eine statistik zu
sprechen wie lange die aufmerksamkeit
dauer ist in die ist also die ist nicht
bei 15 minuten die ist noch weiter
runter hier kann man wie gesagt auch die
folien des vortragenden einbeziehen
ich bin ein großer freund von themen
sendungen podcast oder interviews
experteninterviews die sind nicht zu
lang sind fünf bis zehn minuten länger
dürfen sie wirklich nicht sein
vielleicht sogar nur fünf minuten das
ist noch besser das sind thematisch
spezifisch und vor allem sie sind
dialogisch und interaktiv also hier gibt
es dann häufig zwei personen und die
reden mit ihnen kommunizieren die
stellen fragen und dann kann sich der
rezipient selbst hinein versetzen er
fühlt sich als teil idealer
also dieses videos also das ist so die
chance jetzt gehen wir mal kurz darauf
die aufmerksamkeits dauer eines
durchschnittlichen youtubes nutzers zu
da kann man noch zu sprechen also sie
sehen also die quelle ist you know how
much video ist die beliebte battery
watched also wenn sie mal schauen also
über 30 sekunden sind noch 66 prozent
also zwei drittel schauen sich über 30
sekunden an
aber über drei minuten nur noch 16
prozent und über fünf minuten sogar nur
noch 10 prozent
dass der typische youtube-nutzer das ist
nicht der typische studierende das ist
klar
also aber also der erste eindruck zählt
ne also wirklich da muss man wirklich
viel beten schon am anfang aber das
sollte eine warnung sein auch wenn es
jetzt nur der typische youtube nutzer
ist das video muss von vornherein den
den rezipienten aktivieren das muss
ihnen irgendwie in den bann schlagen
sonst sonst kriegt er weiter das ist
unsere clip mentalität ist aber auch gar
nicht schlimm findet sondern wir können
das als eine chance nutzen uns noch viel
mehr mühe zu geben und das video von
vornherein attraktiv zu machen
und jetzt möchte ich am schluss zum
schluss noch mal auf mein youtube-kanal
philo cast eingehen
der philosophische youtube-kanal hier
fängt das ganze schon arme der
titelgebung und namensgebung für luca
ist gab es zum glück noch nicht
aber uns ist gleich gesichert eine
domain geholt und in youtube kanal dann
zur genannte ist ein eigener
youtube-kanal mit bislang ca 500
abonnenten das ist ganz okay ich bringe
nach ein paar statistiken wir haben
jetzt von gestern auf heute wieder drei
neue bekommen also so pro tag ungefähr
30 springer auch manchmal welche ab sie
haben mit youtube die möglichkeit genau
nachzuverfolgen
zu welchem zeitpunkt zur welcher
veröffentlichung welchen videos die
nutzer bekommen und auch abspringen
sie können sagen zum beispiel dann
dieses video hat mir jetzt nicht neue
nutzer beschert sein im gegenteil da
sind jetzt fünf abgesprungen da muss
irgendwas falsch gemacht haben oder
irgendwie es gibt es ein problem
regelmäßige themen sind im eigenen
studio das hat diese podcast struktur
wir haben das mit zeit lang wirklich
jeden samstag 16 uhr wird das video
freigeschaltet haben jetzt nicht immer
durchgehalten weil wir einfach nicht so
viele videos produziert haben aber in
einer gewissen weise für eine gewisse
phase konnten wir das regelmäßig machen
unser studio ist das sekretariat
wir versuchen die seminar diskussion
aufzugreifen und dann in solchen themen
sind um weiter zu führen
wir bieten interviews mit bekannten
philosophen und philosophen
wir haben dokumentation von
lehrveranstaltungen vorträgen als wenn
zum beispiel meine tagung ist jetzt
diese dann hole ich meine hilfskräfte
last im camcorder aufstellen und nehmen
das mit einverständnis der referierenden
auf ich hatte jetzt in der letzten zeit
ein paar tagungen und versuche immer
noch da an video zu zeigen habe die
referierenden gefragt und die haben
gesagt kein problem ich habe deren
folien mit aufgestellt noch ins video
die waren total dankbar gestern hatten
die ersten 80 jährige philosoph aus
salzburg geschrieben und dann kann man
das an die lowcost app anbinden ich habe
noch eine alte nap gemacht die habe ich
in anderen vortrag genau erklärt und
dann kann man auch die videos damit
einbinden wie sieht jetzt der kanal aus
das ist ein ganz normaler youtube
oberfläche hier ist eben ganz wichtig so
ein logo zu haben in einprägsamen slogan
eule mit zum dr hütchen farbgebung ist
wichtig das hat jetzt zufälligerweise
auf die youtube farben gut gepasst hier
also eine gewisse einheitlichkeit ist
nicht schlecht gestern hatten wir 426
abonnenten heute haben wir jetzt schon
429 und soja also es geht auf die 500 zu
hier sehen sie das angebot das böse ist
für mich ein großes thema gerade da
hatte ich zum beispiel film experten von
der fsk freiwillige selbstkontrolle der
hat mir erzählt was wie das böse im film
vorkommt muss die probleme gibt das ist
eine aufzeichnung einer tagung da ging
es das war jetzt von diesem pv
management da hat frau im haus doping
handels hatten vorteil gehalten den
hatte ich aufgenommen und dann gab es
hier noch einen vortrag auf einen
anderen tagen von mir über
geisteswissenschaften
die logistep will ich ja noch kurz
zeigen
ich hätte ihm genau dasselbe design also
hier diese eule und dann kann man halt
hier in dem menü dann videos quiz und
alles mögliche nicht anschauen hier sind
diese symbole ist bedeutet dass hier
youtube-videos einbezogen sind die
können sie mit wenn sie darauf klicken
können sie das sich direkt in der app
anschauen
ja jetzt will ich ihnen auch kurz zeigen
welche videos bei mir besonders
erfolgreich waren da habe ich eine
statistik sieht man jetzt vielleicht
nicht ganz so gut dass in die top ten
videos die spuck ihnen die gibt ihnen
youtube aus youtube hat eine ganz tolle
analyse und statistikfunktion die immer
aktuell ist ich habe das jetzt
angeordnet nicht nach der wiedergabe
zeit sehen sie weil das kann nicht sein
weil praktisch 4000 minuten sie müssen
an erster stelle stehen ich habe es nach
der anzahl der klicks der aufrufe
gemacht und dann sehen sie georg singles
philosophie das war das war ein
interview
da habe ich eine doktorandin aus bonn
eingeladen auf der tagung hat mit ihrem
anschluss noch ein kurzes interview
gemacht und deshalb extrem viele aufruf
bekommen als fast zehn prozent aller
aufrufe hat es hier dann was gibt es
noch hier hervorzuheben zb hier
millionär durch philosophie studium
das ist so ein bisschen klick welt also
da haben wir dann extra so ein bisschen
ein bisschen provokatives thema genommen
und am anfang wenn sie sich das mal
anschauen sagt nicht der marcel meine
meine mitarbeiter fragt mich jörg was
kann ich mit philosophie machen hast
deine tipps geben du kannst du gleich
arbeitslos melden du hast das fach
studiert also wir provozieren bisschen
und lösen das dann aber auf und somit
kriegt man auch so ein bisschen was man
sollte das jetzt nicht überstrapazieren
hier wimmelt fingers integrierende
middle ages dass es von herrn professor
adams sind er hat uns freundlicherweise
die für apple itunes vorgesehenen videos
auch für youtube gegeben als wir
strahlen die dann parallel auf youtube
aus und das hat auch sehr sehr gute
klickzahlen bekommen hier sehen sie noch
die mag ich bewertungen die halten sich
in der mehr zeit die mag ich nicht sind
hier gering bzw diesen kommentar habe
ich 15
die kommentare und hier gibt es jetzt
ein zeit dazu wir haben auch noch bei
anderen videos man könnte sich das jetzt
noch so ausspucken dass es nach anzahl
der kommentare geben dann haben wir noch
bei anderen videos mir aber es könnte
durchaus noch mehr sein
jetzt zu der anzahl der aufrufe pro tag
sie werden da war es interessant dass
sich eine spitze im sommer dieses jahres
und diese spitze ist sind die videos von
herrn professor adams und ihr uns zur
verfügung gestellt hat die haben wir
rein gestellt und da haben wir wirklich
ein ganz tolles spitze bekommen und
seitdem geht es auch letztendlich immer
weiter auf hier gab es einen kleinen
einbruch hier aber es geht wieder hoch
und wir sind pro tag bei circa 70 würde
ich mal sagen ca 70 videos werden pro
tag aufgrund das ist ganz ordentlich
die durchschnittliche wiedergabe dauer
kann man sich auch anzeigen lassen
das sind fünf minuten 58 diesen
praktisch sechs minuten und es ist auch
ziemlich gut wenn sie mal schauen dass
über nach dieser youtube mobile
statistik eigentlich nur sehr wenige
leute über fünf prozent über fünf
minuten anschauen haben wir doch hier
ziemlich stabile ansichts kurve die
wiedergabe orte auch noch kurz wir haben
hier die youtube wiedergabe seite dass
es die die sie gesehen haben die hat 95
prozent die allermeisten schauen sie das
von der youtube seite an und 5 prozent
schauen sich über die app an
also aus dieser flug a step jetzt kann
man sich fragen lohnt sich das überhaupt
gut ich glaube schon aber ist ein
zusätzliches angebot
jetzt will ich ihnen noch kurzen bild
zeigen ich denke zum video reicht es
nicht mehr ich wäre dann auch hier ein
link reinmachen hier ganz oben dieses
kästchen zu dem nächsten video nämlich
das interview mit der psychiaterin dr
nasa
kennt jemand von ihnen also die ist
recht bekannt die hat bei ganz brutalen
morden und sonstigen fällen hat sie
gutachten erstellt von den tätern jetzt
kürzlich kamen sie auch wieder in den
medien und die habe ich interviewt zum
thema des bösen alles böse aus
psychiatrischer perspektive
und das kam ganz gut an da haben uns die
mühe gegeben haben hinaus kleine namens
einblendung gemacht hier von von links
sie sehen dass bei diesem studium sie
haben vorhin die totale gesehen von oben
da war sie drin und dann haben jetzt
noch hier ein vortrag von professor
edgar morscher über das sein sollen
problem
das war einem anderen raum und da haben
wir auch mit dem camcorder mit dem
vortrag aufgenommen auch hier ist der
link zum video oben eingeblendet und wir
haben hier dann auch in diesem video
folien seine präsentation noch rein rein
gelegt so dass man das als sich gut
anschauen kann
herr professor moshe war so nett uns
auch seine power point präsentation zur
verfügung zu stellen dass wir sie
verlinken konnten direkt unter dem video
also dass man drauf blick und die
powerpoint auch noch hat das macht
natürlich nicht alle platzieren weil sie
sagen das ist ja auch rechtlich
irgendwie ein problem
ja ich denke wir ich bin am ende jetzt
angekommen habe jetzt eine halbe stunde
gesprochen ich bedanke mich vielmals für
die aufmerksamkeit